what should people do people should
[__] stop complaining people should
figure out who the [__] they are figure
out what you [__] put you on fire and
you're halfway decent at if you're lucky
enough right now to be listening and
you're good at what you like become
tunnel [__] Vision because there's
way too many voices telling you what and
how have the conversation with the
person that's holding you back the
reason most people who are listening
right now are not doing that thing is
they're worried about the opinion of
somebody we have to get to a place where
you're doing you because the number one
thing that scares the [__] out of me is
regret and you're gonna sit there at 72
and you're gonna say I wish I wish I
wish and whether that's money or spend
more time with your family there's a
million ways to do this